hey guys Pete here this is a
conversation I had with Hugh Howey the
author that wrote the book series The
Silo TV show is based on in case you
were wondering I wanted to give a quick
spoiler warning we mostly talk about
everything that happened in season one
including the finale we also talk about
some of the adaptation choices related
to the books and get into some of what
he knows about season 2 filming which is
already underway but there are no Major
Spoilers about future story points to
worry about and with that out of the way
let's get into it
why do they care so much
your tape is way better than theirs yeah
I know doesn't make any sense
unless it does
all right now that the first season of
Silo is complete I wanted to talk about
the great finale and where things are
going next with the series
and who better to do that with than the
guy who wrote the books
so today I'm happy to introduce you
Howie how's it going
it's going great man can't believe the
first season is already behind us it's
crazy yeah it kind of flies by doesn't
it
if yeah like when uh agonizingly slow
and then super fast somehow like the
weeks felt so long in between episodes
yeah I was following along with the uh
the little videos that you're putting
out after each episode and um thought
that was really an interesting way to do
that and I've seen you out there quite a
bit talking to people and sort of
engaging so
um yeah it's nice to see that people are
responding to it it's got a pretty good
reception I mean we've already got a
season two
started is that right
Yep they're well underway filming
um I've been watching dailies and it's
um season two is Bonkers it's it it is
so crazy watching what they're putting
together yeah I can't I'm really happy
to see this is working out um I was a
fan of the books I read them I'm not
sure what year it would have been but
it's been a little bit of time since I
first discovered them uh and then I went
back and reread them before the series
started and I do have one before we get
into like all the stuff that everyone's
here that wants to hear I do have one
question that I want answered like on a
personal level I guess is sort of a
nerdy one sure but I remember when I
first read the books back then
I had this idea in my head that they
were all wearing coveralls like they
were all wearing those like jumpsuits um
like maybe something like you see a
mechanic wearing at the auto dealership
or whatever you know so when I went back
it it it's overalls
so is this like a Mandela effect like
where I I just
you know like had the different thing in
my head and or or what's going on there
what did they wear in the silo inside
the books
um that's funny is it overall I always
thought it was cover us as well maybe
maybe we there's a glitch in The Matrix
yeah I always just I always assumed they
had sleeves but
um again who knows they could have what
we call coveralls and they just call
them overalls because you know
over all your other bits and pieces
um all right well yeah that's funny yeah
it I was just like as I know in the show
they changed it and that probably makes
sense right
um I like the idea of them all wearing
the same things with different colors
I think it would look a little too
um
to sci-fi or something it's kind of how
in comic books superheroes look like
they're supposed to be
basically nude with just painted colors
on them you know skin type and then you
do it in live action it just looks dumb
um which is why a lot of Marvel movies
they spend most of the time like in
regular clothes
um
so yeah I think there's been a lot of
people like they're supposed to be
wearing like all the same color but it
wouldn't it wouldn't have looked as cool
as the the what the Wardrobe Department
pulled off yeah I mean I do think in the
book it was it made for it added to the
atmosphere of things like it you know it
was fun to imagine it that way but yeah
sometimes whenever you go from the book
to the TV show there there's there's
things that work a lot better
that's the genius of Graham as a
showrunner and his writers they you know
they spent a lot of time thinking about
these decisions and and trying to
imagine like is this going to look right
if we if we do a direct translation and
I think this is one of the ones that
they really got right to not uh not go
with when I first started I was like any
other reader I was like no you know we
should do this and then I thought ah
you're right this is it's gonna look a
little hokey if we and and also the
characters won't have as much
individuality but in the books it really
helps set aside the class differences in
our minds yeah yeah yeah I like whenever
there's I guess I can't I was going to
talk about something that I can't
actually talk about because it's it's
later
um but yeah there are times whenever
they identify each other by colors and
it's it's really effective to kind of
set the scene that way like I said I I
do
want to congratulate you I mean I think
that this has been a success
um for a brand new show it seems like
there's been nothing but good news
across the board as far as it's being
received
what does that feel like
uh it's a it's a huge relief because a
lot went into getting this made and you
never know you know when you're going to
get another shot at getting something
adapted
um and you just don't want to upset uh
all the fans that's my first concern
like all the people who've been wanting
this for so long I just want them to be
happy my next concern is like a lot of
uh publishing Partners around the world
um kind of priced in an adaptation when
they when they bought the series because
there was a lot of hype about Ridley
Scott making a film out of this years
ago and I I just want them to earn back
you know what they've invested and then
all the people who've worked hard on the
show you want them to have a good
reception because you know it's just sad
seeing things come out and and get bad
reviews a bunch of people worked on
every one of those projects
but yeah
um to say that it went well as like
really to put a mildly it's it's been
the the number one drama Apple has ever
had
um I I've been checking in with with
everyone there and at AMC who helped
launch this and everyone's just over the
moon like it's people had hopes for it
when they saw what we were putting
together uh internally they had hopes
but it's it's exceeded everyone's
expectations which is very rare
gotta love it though right yeah man I
mean it's just you know I've got you
know Stephen King's a fan of the show
which is cool he's been tweeting all
about it and yeah um it's the the
reviews it's I love seeing on Rotten
Tomatoes that the critics and the
reviewers both are super happy because
that doesn't always happen either yeah
that's true that is one of the things I
wanted to ask you was it's been a long
process right I mean as as far as I
could tell you actually sold the film
rights way back like right after like
maybe a year after you started
publishing all the short stories that
would eventually be called wool right
yeah I think we did that we do we
actually were in discussions with Ridley
before the the fifth part of the first
book came out so wool wasn't even
completed and just on the strength of
the first four parts and how well they
were selling
um I'd already written a rough draft of
the fifth part and so we sent that out
to a bunch of uh film people
and uh an auction was brewing
um
uh on the book because before it hit the
New York Times list or any of that stuff
so
um uh it's been since like early 2012.
the whole time I just enjoyed the
process and haven't expected anything to
actually get made to be sitting here
talking to you now after a first season
under our ballot a second season filming
and the kind of reception we've had it
just feels like an absolute dream yeah
so I did want to I mean this is probably
a question you get all the time it's
probably something that people have have
heard I mean I I certainly know the
answers to this question I guess but I
do see that a lot of my viewers this is
their first experience with it is is the
actual TV show they didn't they've never
heard of the story they didn't read it
beforehand
and they're in love with it so would you
be able to give those people a brief
history of how this all started because
it's a it's a really interesting story
yeah it's insane really I
um
my first book was with a small a
published with a small press and what
I've learned from that process was like
I'm I don't think Publishers are for me
I want to just self-publish and so I was
working in a little bookstore in North
Carolina and writing novels on the side
and
um at the time that I it was what was
like my seventh published work and um at
the time I was making like maybe a
hundred dollars a month on Direct ebook
and print sales you know it wasn't
making a career out of this but I was
and this was this was pretty early in
that in that that sort of trend right I
mean this wasn't an established way to
to make a living yet at this point was
it no this the stigma I had to go
through while self-publishing was
unbelievable I was in a writing group up
in North Carolina and
um they all thought you know I was an
idiot and everyone I talked to online
when I when I because I bought the
rights back to my first book like I I
went from having a traditional path to
going all in on self-publishing and
everyone said even my publisher they
said this is the biggest mistake you'll
ever make but I was happy I just wanted
to write my kind of stories wool was a
like 56 pages when it was published it
was just the the story of Holston
and there's no other way to publish that
like it's too long for a magazine it's
too short for a publisher but you know
Kindle readers they don't care if you
I'm charging 99 Cents for something you
can read on your lunch break it seemed
like a fair transaction for everybody
and
I was at work one day just looking at my
sales stuff and uh wool was like
outselling everything I'd ever published
before and I I checked on Amazon and the
reviews were like at the beginning every
review was a five-star review it was
insane the reaction they had to that
short story
and uh the only thing they said was
where's the rest of the story like we
want more
and I dropped the novel that I was
writing at the time and started
um releasing the rest of the novel in a
serialized form
it was a lot of fun because I was on
Facebook and on my blog like
um just talking about the process and
and interacting with readers while they
were falling in love with these stories
and the next few months were just crazy
like all five parts of wool just climbed
up the best on the list on Amazon and
and within a month or two I was making
enough that I put my notice in my day
job and just concentrated on writing
yeah so it was just it was like it was
like a a community instead of here's a
book and then it does well we were doing
something organically together
and my first like thousand fans on
Facebook were really proud of like how
how early on they were they called
themselves the Thousand yeah and a lot
of them are with you know enjoying this
ride and and interacting with me every
day still they've been a part of this
process for like 12 years now
yeah and I think that it's strange but I
think that the way that that's put
together actually
adds to some of the of what the early
appeal of the story is because
what I liked about it I think the first
time I didn't read it individually I
read it after it was all I guess all
complete um you know the first two books
at least were complete I think um so
what I like though was that there was
this steady
pace of revealing things like it was
asking questions and it was revealing
things and and I wonder now looking back
I mean it seems like a lot of that was
because like you said the first book was
just about Holston and and Allison right
so you kind of had to answer all those
questions in that 56 Pages rather than
leave them for
uh you know the end of the book or
something like that
so yeah yeah it's a great point because
if uh if I'd written that as a novel a
lot of what you learn at on page 56 I
would have saved from page 500 right and
um and I think the I think it's made for
a really fun uh TV show adaptation
because we get to like you know show a
lot of our hand really early on
and yeah the people who are not readers
and who are just viewers are like
they're expecting every episode to have
like some like that we should be you
know on a different planet by now like
they want that level of pace but the the
TV show is followed kind of what the
book did where you had this explosive
opening and then you have a build up to
Juliet and how when she gets the same
information that Allison had the results
are completely different
and why the results are different depend
on what happens you know over all these
other reveals throughout the story
so I I I lucked into an amazing
um uh like like we we wouldn't be able
to catch the characters we cached it if
we didn't kill some of them off because
of availability yeah yeah and so we're
able to like go get like just like
getting David and getting Rashida
um uh it's uh just dumb lucky the way it
all worked out
yeah and there's a real balance that you
have to I mean I think this is where you
know working with someone like gram yose
you know you get you get some some
experience in there of like there's a
risk when you get some characters that
are that appealing and that people are
gonna go for that hard in the beginning
of the story and then they're dead you
know like completely removed from it by
the second episode and then you have to
restart that process of introducing
someone new so
there's a little bit of a gamble there
and um
I mean how do you feel like that they
navigated that do you feel like that
that was uh something that that that
translates well to TB and then in this
format of like 10 episodes and the
longer the longer narrative
yeah I I love it because I I just went
back and watched the pilot again
um they uh Apple stream the entire thing
on Twitter even though I could go watch
it on like 10 of 1080p on my yeah big
screen upstairs I was like I've never
seen a um Studio do this before so I had
it running in a window while I was
getting work done and just you know
what's awesome is we will never lose
David and Rashida and and that pilot and
seeing David and Rebecca together
in the in the second episode
and um it's always there for us to go
like spend time with them again yeah um
what's what's great for me I think is
like all the other characters we get to
spend time with if if we didn't kill
these people off like Paul Billings is
so much more fleshed out in the TV show
than he is in the book
um
uh Kennedy the this uh yeah we just
spent time with again at the end of
episode uh nine and and who opens uh in
episode 10 he becomes a huge part of
this show and even into season two
um and he's he kind of landed in our lap
like
um it's one of those situations where
the actor is so good and so magnetic on
screen that you're like all right how do
we make this a bigger role so it's it's
it's very similar to what happens with
writers writers are terrified of killing
off characters because once you have a
character people love they do so much
heavy lifting for you but you have to
have confidence in yourself like we know
that we could put together more
characters people are going to fall in
love with
and going going into season two you're
gonna spend a lot more time with the
people in mechanical so we have
incredible cast down there in Harriet he
plays walker uh with Shirley with Knox
um and I can't wait for people to spend
more time with these actors
yeah so we're in that weird period of
time like you and I right now people
will see this after but we've we've both
seen the finale it hasn't hit yet so you
haven't seen the reaction to this
um I mean I like it yeah I liked it a
lot I I think that it was a it was a
good place to stop I I had that feeling
when I was in the middle of the Season
I'm like are they gonna get the whole
book and then I realized okay they're
not so what's where's the spot where
would I stop and you know I think that
was the natural answer you know what
where where you did where you chose to
do that whenever you think about that
closing shot right
um what are you hoping that people are
seeing whenever they they look out into
that world that that she's just entered
uh well I I think you know I don't know
what percentage won't expect it because
you've got
um quite a few readers who are waiting
for that moment uh a lot of people who
are new to the show have already guessed
like there's got to be more than one
Silo
um and and are feeling like that might
be the twist at the end
um but I would say maybe half the
audience won't see it coming or know for
sure
and I hope they feel what I felt when I
was writing that originally which is
a multiplication of the despondency that
you feel in in Wool when you're an
intern sorry it's the wool is the book
but and when you're watching silo you
got all these people going through
really tough times and when you stick
your head over that Hill which when I
wrote this I was I was literally
thinking about Sid Arthur
um sticking his head over the wall of
the palace uh if you're familiar with uh
Buddhism and the how the the philosophy
got started said Arthur was
contemplating life and I think he heard
someone wailing or something in the
streets and looked over the wall and
realized he lived in a very cloistered
uh luxurious kind of Palace setting and
he just saw that Humanity was bigger
than his imagination
and that's what wanted him to figure out
how to end in suffering his own
suffering and then suffering for the
people
and
you've got this like really dark story
and you think things are terrible and
when you pop up you realize hey other
people are going through really
bad things as well and you quickly
discover people have gone through worse
things
the way you thought your problems were
huge the problems of the world are even
bigger
um
it's uh the sort of the the circles of
intro of uh empathy that we're really
talking about here and it's it's so
subconscious I mean I'm conscious when
I'm writing it but it's a subconscious
hope that when people see that they just
feel all the emotions they felt for That
season have this kind of multiplied
effect
and then there's there's an amazing like
hatch mystery there like oh my God
that's what's Happening Here what is
happening in all these other ones and
who are those people and when do we get
to meet some of them yeah I whenever I I
was was wanted to ask you about the
inspiration for this because it makes me
think about Plato's allegory of the cave
you know because of the way that they're
literally underground and they they they
only see that part of reality that
they're allowed to see and you know so
that was the inspiration for the
original story for sure okay that's I
think that comes through
um but so that's good and you know I was
making my video about the the final and
I I use that a lot so it's good to hear
you say that so that I won't have to um
to go and edit it but um yeah so I mean
I think that's something that when you
think about the way the show is put
together and the way that everything
falls into place there at the end
I think that's the thing that people
will come to as they they realize right
that she's going out into the world and
nobody like you can't really say what
that is but I mean that's such a huge
difference from where she was at the
beginning where she wants to just be
there working and taking care of this
thing that's right in front of her and
making sure that everybody has power so
that you know
she is of service you know that she has
a purpose there
and now it's like
just because she wanted to learn the
truth about what would happen to this
person that she cared about
now she's going into somewhere
completely uh different
yeah I think what's cool about her
journey in this episode is she starts
off
um really having a hard time having
relationships with people
but over the course of this episode it's
her relationships with people that
actually keep saving her and propelling
her forward
um you know her relationship with Walker
saves her her relationship with her
fellow mechanics like Shirley but also
the relationship she develops with
Billings
um uh all these
um people that have a hard time trusting
her
uh and and the Holston had the same kind
of
um kind of swinging emotions about her
um they come to admire that she's very
competent and she you know where you
stand with her and she uh has the right
motivations like she's not
selfishly motivated at all she's always
trying to figure out like how to
sacrifice for the good of uh of her
friends or for the silo and I love that
she's like rewarded for those
interpersonal
um bits of growth that she has in the in
the first season
yeah because I mean I thought that but I
mean that was my impression and what
what I really liked watching this as
someone who knows where the story's
going is that a lot of what's there with
the character felt really intentional
you know it felt like it was all
connected to things that will
pay off later basically you know without
giving anything away
so I I was really surprised where I saw
some fans who who
thought that she was that that
abrasiveness that she has that like a
little bit of like
social awkwardness or whatever you would
call it you know the way that she's just
not really good around people you know
you kind of made that point in the book
about her
liking machines like being more
comfortable with machines than she is
with people like they misunderstood that
for somehow her being selfish or being
an unlikable character but I I never
read her that way I I thought of it more
real as a relatable character where she
you know she has her flaws but she she
is at the bottom of everything you know
she's she's there trying to
do more you know do more good than than
harm
yeah she's so devoted to her job and and
her crew as well like uh she
um is other mechanics look up to her
because she just gets it done
um I I love like viewer frustration and
reader frustration is a good thing I
think if if people are just happy about
everything then they don't they're not
in for a fun ride the fact the fact that
people are like she's not likable I like
that because it means that they want
their protagonists to be likable and
that's the journey that she's on so if
they if they you know nourish that
dissatisfaction and stick with the show
then they're gonna be rewarded with an
amazing character art yeah um but I
don't I don't enjoy it I think some
people are into it are what what they in
literature we call them Mary Sue's which
are these Perfect characters that
um it often happens because the author
is trying to it's like a worship moment
they want their character to be perfect
in all the ways that they're not and I'm
the opposite I want my characters to be
as flawed as I am yeah and to have some
room for growth
it seems like it'll be more fun to write
those ones
it's so much more fun to write I I I
I've always
um
you know I I don't know what scars you
have on your body but we all have scars
like I'm talking about literal scars
yeah and if we look over each one has a
story
um you know I uh
when I'm trimming up a character you
can't just have this like you know 38
year old blank canvas that's never been
in love so the first you know you write
about them falling in love like it's the
first time like you gotta remember that
when they were teenagers they had their
heart broken and and you gotta remember
that their pockets are full of mementos
and things that they carry with them
every day
and I think giving characters that depth
is makes it so much more rewarding to to
write about
yeah I agree I I I think that's you know
I think that
whenever I thought about this becoming a
TV show that that's what I hoped to see
was that we would um get to look at
these characters and get to know them
better because that's really what TV
does well you know what I mean that
that's that's sort of what it excels at
you have all these different mediums and
they all sort of have their their
strengths and I think that you know
being able to watch this character for
for multiple hours and and see her go
through multiple things and in the way
that she changes and then realizing that
you do know her and you have a
connection to her I mean that's where TV
really
really kind of you know
can can be moving you know so yeah and
we get to instead of cutting things out
which is what we would do if we made a
feature we get to add stuff so
um in episode uh nine you get to see
um sims's wife make a really interesting
decision and then have a conversation
with Robert about how they have a bigger
goal and you're like what the heck is
this yeah that's exactly what I say
yeah so you know we want
um when we're in the writer's room we're
like okay how can we make a story that
is great for people who are unfamiliar
with the material but then how can we
also make readers who feel like they
um know this story you know by heart
how do we get them on the edge of their
seats as well and TV allows you to do
that you get to come up with all these
subplots that that are new to
um The Source material
yeah I do have a question about you know
um you obviously you can't answer it but
I do have a question about what's going
on with with
Mrs Sims I don't know if that her name
is I don't know if she's been called by
her first name I know in the credits I
didn't catch it so
I do have an idea I do have a question
about what's going on with her and then
also Billings like you said you've added
a lot of a lot to that character
um he's he was basically he just
basically just there to do a job in in
the book as far as I remember and so
we're we get to know a lot about him
again he's one of he's a complicated
character he he's mostly good but at the
same time he's everything that he does
is is sort of because I mean it's all
based on this lie that he's telling that
he doesn't want to know what happened we
see him we see that get exposed in the
finale
but then something weird happens he gets
to become Sheriff anyways so I'm I'm
really curious about that because in
this in the episode before
we saw that he had he had seen you know
he had that perception he had that
alteration of perception right he saw
the the book he saw the same book that
Juliet saw a few episodes back and and
he has different ideas about what's what
the world is at this point
and so yeah I thought I thought that was
very very interesting way to end the
season for his character because there's
a lot going on there you know he's so
complex
um one of my favorite characters in the
show
um just when you think about what's
going on with him internally uh what I
loved about
um his reaction to that book you know
this is a guy who who's
follows the pack so closely he wins like
you know the packed version of a
spelling bee and he knows what to do
with this Relic when he sees this book
like this is this has to be turned in
and it's like too big of a shock for him
to even do that so he's just got to
destroy it that's the only thing he can
think to do and then there's a part of
him that can't
get rid of all of it yeah and it's just
pain it's painful for viewers to know
that there's not many photographs like
this left yeah and you're gonna you're
gonna set them on fire like watching
that burn is painful for me every single
time
yeah because you think back to Gloria
too right you you think about her saying
you know you're the only one that can
keep this alive and then to see that
pretty quickly as far as the you know
the story time goes be destroyed
yeah and how good Billings is it at his
job just thinking about okay where did
where did Juliet think to hide something
in the past and then uh to uncover the
way he did is is absolute genius and
shows how good he would be at that job
but I think you know the reason people
want him in that job is is he's always
seemed Meek
um and that's because he's hiding yes uh
the syndrome which doesn't let him be
his full self he's constantly worried
about being seen and if he didn't have
that
um stigma uh you you could just see in
that moment of him being by himself and
being a detective how he would 100 be a
great uh Kenneth to replace Holston
um which is so ironic because all the
the good guys didn't want him in that
job in the first place but the reason
people in judicial and in I.T want him
and that that role is because they feel
like he's someone they can manipulate
and and I love that about this character
because he's not he's he's not he's got
he's principled and complex and
um in the book that was the idea in the
heart of this character that
what we need for uh a just Society our
uh people in positions of power to make
difficult and good decisions and that's
what he does on the way up with um you
know I can't I don't want to spoil
anything from viewers because this is
now getting towards the end of the first
novel but billings's character makes
decisions based on Justice rather than
um personal game and we see everyone
else like
more torn in that department or leaning
towards doing things that'll benefit
them rather than just thinking about
self-sacrifice
and and I think by the end of the season
is that even that is a little bit murky
right
um when you think about Bernard
I think the show did a good job of kind
of
adding some Dimensions to his character
too yeah is he is he a bad guy like I
I'm still not
settle on that like uh
I mean you know he's a murderer or he
you know he has he has some connection
to that but you do get the sense that
he's doing this because he thinks it's
the right thing but not even just the
right thing but that
it's necessary for their survival it's
yeah I think there's like two different
there's two different mindsets if you
kill a person right I'm sure I'm sure
there's a lot more but here's two of
them
um one of them is here's a terrible
person and I'm gonna get satisfaction
from ending their life
I don't think Bernard has ever felt that
um yeah the other is uh if I kill this
person I'm Gonna Save ten thousand lies
and that's what you know there's a war
going on right now in Ukraine and people
who were you know in these trenches
um I and this is my bias because I'm
pulling for Ukraine in this situation
but
um I don't think there's a lot of people
who are like excited to get up and kill
someone that day
but they're thinking like I if I do this
it'll protect my family it'll protect my
whole it'll give us a place that we're
able to live a safe free life
and my feeling is that when Bernard does
something bad he really believes that I
am saving lives today
and
understanding that mindset I think
really helps us empathize with people
who are doing things that we think are
Unforgivable
yeah it doesn't make them right it's
just in their minds what their what the
way that they're justifying their
actions is completely different than the
pure evil that we like to put on them
yeah that was that was my takeaway as
well
um like I said in the book he was just I
think he came off as a little bit
I thought one of my first read I thought
that he did seem to kind of enjoy that
position of power that he had a little
bit more like he was a little more
in your face about it it seemed like uh
and so this this was this was nice and I
guess that by pulling the character of
Sims up and and adding this um and
adding this layer of judicial in there
instead of him being like his his Direct
Security advisor or whatever the role
was in the book that that kind of gives
you a little bit more room to play like
at first you think it's Sims and then
you find out it's Bernard but then
really they're both they're both kind of
motivated by this idea of the the
survival of the of of the group rather
than anything on the individual basis
yeah for sure
so yeah we've talked about quite a few
different changes and
you know some of the different ways that
the you know adapting something like
this is you know how that process goes
you mentioned the writer's room so you
you're on whenever whenever they you
know whenever they break a season you're
there you're involved with that process
throughout
yeah for the the mini room where we set
up the pilot in the first season we just
had a couple of weeks meeting every day
in in La this is before the um the
pandemic kind of uh just I don't know
four or five months before
um so we uh kind of outlined the whole
show and even thought about what would
happen in the subsequent season so we
knew how many seasons it would take
because um when we pitched this to the
headset AMC and apple who teamed up to
to put the show together
um you know we had to kind of and we had
to have budget in mind you know like
yeah what's our what's your cash how
many how many
um settings and what's you know what's
uh what do we mean out of
um sets and stuff like that
um and so we had to kind of block all
that out roughly
um every episode we had
um outlined and then the pilot we had a
real detailed outline
um yeah since then
um the writers kind of know where we're
heading and and when we break a new
season I'll come in and help brainstorm
and and answer questions to give
guidance but
um my uh main contribution is to read
all the scripts and just give detailed
notes which is a producer role than a
writer role oh yeah for sure and when I
when I watch the episodes now it's a lot
of fun to see like the areas where I you
know I noticed the weakness and gave a
note and see like the change and how
much stronger it is and uh you know yeah
I feel like I'm I'll probably make the
show uh better and not worse which is my
fear of going into this and I would just
screw something up
yeah
um it is a different thing it's a
different Beast uh screenwriting as
opposed to to writing a novel and or in
this case a series of stories that
became a novel and I've obviously
written you've written you've written
quite a few things over the years
um pretty much every different way
do you have a do you have an interest in
screenwriting is that something that you
want to pursue more in the future or are
you
happy to just keep pumping out books no
I love screenwriting we
um my writing partner and I created a
new show for AMC
um last year that we can't go forward
with into a writer's room now because of
the writer strike but
um we wrote an amazing pilot and We've
ran a few Pilots together
um and a feature like we we love working
together and I love the medium so it's
definitely something I want to keep
doing but um I'm going to keep writing
stories because uh those will actually
see the light of day when I'm when I'm
working on a screenplay I always assume
okay this might uh you know get me uh a
paycheck or some hard work to flesh it
out more but you never you never know if
it's gonna actually get made and enjoyed
by an audience
and I'm spoiled with books I know when I
write something that someone's going to
read it so I I still enjoy that more
what would you say your favorite change
from the the original story to the TV
show is
oh wow um we've talked a lot about a few
of them just the fact that we got to
flesh out more characters but the the
biggest thing for me is that we got to
show Olson and and Juliet working
together on a case because in the book
you know what because of the way I
release these Holliston was dead before
I introduced Juliet
and so I could mention that they work
together on a case but
um you know he wasn't there for me to to
have them in the room together
and the way we got to tell the story on
the TV show we get a whole episode of
the two of them interacting and that was
definitely the most enjoyable
change yeah yeah I would put that up
there I I also like the um the Bernard
stuff I thought that that some of the
stuff that was going on with him the way
that he sort of
he was cunning right he he he he
tricked Juliet in a way you know like he
he left his options open right like he
was maybe if it would maybe if it made
sense to stay behind her and keep her in
the position then he would be all right
with that and you know then he got that
really
kind of satisfying thing I mean it was
it was devastating but it was also kind
of satisfying to see it play out in the
in the cornfield at the end of uh
whenever he finally revealed that you
know he was he was out to get the hard
drive
you're pretty happy with the way that
the pacing went up I think like I said
that this is probably the natural place
to end this first season if you if there
was a different way that you would have
kind of broken it up how would that have
gone down like would you could you have
do you think you could have sped the
story up at all or
you know if if you tried to tell the
whole novel in one season I think it
would feel so rushed um it would be
really difficult for casting too
yeah and and for said dressing as well
um for reasons you know you and I know
as readers but we uh can talk about
um covering the TV show but um yeah it'd
be it would have been really difficult
and I think
um what's I think uh if if people are
watching this and they feel like I want
more happening every episode
um when you when you binge this like
after uh today people aren't waiting a
week anymore between episodes like that
that whole you and I got to enjoy those
two months
and that'll never be that that way again
and there'll be new viewers now for
years and they're gonna watch the whole
thing in a couple of sittings probably
so it's gonna feel like a a long film
you know
um I don't think they're gonna
you know at the end of a 45 minute
episode say not enough happened this
week they're gonna hit next episode
and they're basically going to watch
half of a novel you know over a eight
hour
period and I I don't think he was going
to say like not enough happened here but
I totally get it when you're watching
this week to week I felt the same way
when I was watching lost or whatever I'd
be like oh my God you're stringing this
along like when when are you gonna get
to something when are you gonna get to
the Smoke monster when are you gonna I
answer all my questions but that's not
really what uh what people want they I I
think the frustration is part of the
process and yeah if people are happy the
whole time you're doing something wrong
yeah I would say you know the first time
I watched it because I had so much
anticipation of seeing the things I knew
was going to happen you know what I mean
like I I know where it's going or I
think I do from reading the book so
there were at times when I thought like
well why don't we know this yet or
something like that but
since I covered TV and I'm always
talking about it and I'm always thinking
about it you know I've had this
experience before so I know that that
that's kind of what it is right it's
it's me it's my expectation of what's
going to happen next but when I can step
back and and look at it again then I
realize what no this is actually really
this is really you know layered
character stuff that's going on and then
it's going to pay off in the in the
future and so you know I don't think the
average person thinks about that so much
you know and a lot of times when I hear
people say stuff like that like nothing
happened or something and I'm like well
what are the shows that you're watching
that where there is something happening
every time also I I don't want to make a
story I don't want to make a show that
that appeals to those viewers right
right nothing against them but it's a
minority of unhappy viewers most people
watching the show
um when Juliet realizes that her dad uh
I'll get i'll get Terry just talk about
this when she realizes that her dad
didn't turn her mom in and he wasn't
what destroyed their lives and she
forgives him
and says you know he's like I miss her
every day and she's like me too and I
love you and and they're holding each
other you can't get that moment without
everything that comes before the
flashbacks with
um you know even with knowing what
Allison went through with having her
birth control taken out and knowing that
this doctor is complicit in that system
but he wasn't you know part of the
problem that that got um his wife in
trouble like
you you have to invest in a whole bunch
of different little threads to get that
moment and when I go back in and think
about the season it's moments like that
um or Paul telling you know telling his
wife like you know I punched this kid
and and you're like oh my God this is
the guy who's so nice and obeys all the
rules and he had like how do you pull
that off in a single episode you just
can't
so
um if you if you make a show that caters
to the angry viewer you'll make a
terrible show right they don't exist the
shows that they're talking about really
don't exist you know I just ignore them
like I think the creators have lost uh
have admitted to this that they were
watching this is the first show Lost
where social media and blogs and online
writing
um became so uh loud that the creators
were listening to uh the show Heroes is
another one where this happened and the
people writing it are like okay here are
these 10 people who are really
you know uh got really strong opinions
about this how do we make a show for
those 10 people
and you can start to lose what made the
show have that kind of outpouring of of
interest in the first place yeah so I I
think what what we've done with this
show is make the kind of show that we
want to watch knowing that there's a lot
of other people out there like us
yeah that and that's a great that's a
great way to look at it right I mean
that's
that's the dream right your story and
and make your show the thing that you
would want to see if you you know if you
could
we're getting close to the end of our
time is there anything that you would
like to hint at or
give fans in relation to the the
upcoming second season
man I wish I could I I will say
um
watching what where what we filmed so
far and being on set for season two
some of the shots some of the things
that were
capturing on film it's some of the most
beautiful TV I've ever seen and I'm so
critical of of any project that I'm
actually involved in like
um I'm always having I'm a really
um negative eye towards anything because
I'm looking for any problem that needs
to be solved and I I'm getting
Goosebumps just watching what we're
putting together for season two so
um it's gonna be a really difficult long
way but it's
um I hope people enjoy this first season
because the next one's gonna blow your
mind we got there in a different way but
I feel like we're we're at the same
place we were in the book right I mean
this isn't a huge departure from from
the story it's more about the adaptation
to the different medium and and sort of
hitting those same same points so
I'm curious because there are some there
are some different things about the way
that the second book is structured and
things like that
have you guys discussed how you'll move
past that if you get you know renewed um
for a third season or
where are you at in that kind of uh you
know as far as planning
yeah we know how we want to tell the
whole show
um I'm the I'm never confident we're
gonna get like anything uh out of
Hollywood but the reception to this
first season and seeing how invested
um apple is with uh the second season
and and the writing that we've gotten
done on the third before the um
before the writer strike I have a
feeling we're going to get to tell this
whole story and we know how we want to
tell the second and third books and and
how long that'll take and it's
um it's very manageable so
um dancing dancing around what I can say
I think we're gonna get to tell the
whole story
and tell it in a way that is very
satisfying I will say
um any any reader who's hoping that
we're faithful to the books if that's
the measure of how much they enjoy the
show
um we're gonna deviate
um going forward because there's just a
better way to to tell some of this story
and
um we're gonna break from the book in in
some major ways and we're gonna
do some fan service by sticking to the
book and and other ways that are that
are really dear to my heart and other
people on this show who are huge fans of
the source material
but if I know I I'm a huge fan of of uh
fan fiction the oral tradition of
telling stories in different ways I
think if you think the book is better
then think of these as two different
stories being told hundreds of years
from now about similar events and the
two stories diverge on the details but
these
um are you know different people's
accounts of what happened
um and a momentous time like
go read the four gospels in the Bible
and they tell very different versions of
of the same stories like huge details
really important things like the last
thing Jesus said on the cross are
different across three of the books
so Embrace that stop being so pedantic
and worrying about like this is a little
different from the book like
um
when we're not trying to do a frame by
frame retelling of an old story yeah and
uh I think people are going to have to
embrace that as we go forward because
we're gonna
some big deviations in the future that I
hope blow readers minds and they're like
oh my God you really mess with my brain
there
yeah I mean I I think that you know the
what I love about books I mean I I books
are my my favorite thing basically you
know I've been reading like a maniac
since I was a little kid
and I you know
everything I like about that is it is
that it exists in my in my head you know
when I'm watching TV I want I want to be
taken somewhere else in a different way
and and I you know and what what really
makes a an adaptation works is if I can
if any if I experience the same
feelings the same you know if I get to
the same place in a different way
and then I have a new experience with
that same thing if that makes sense you
know perfectly said that's exactly what
I want you know out of this as well so
I'm a huge reader as well yeah you know
and I know we're closer of our time but
Watchman was one of those great examples
of a film that was kind of a one-to-one
adaptation that was good but it was we'd
already seen the story and then they did
a TV show that was genius and had all
the same
emotions of the source material without
trying to retell it and I'm more of a
fan of the latter than the former yeah
So speaking of reading what have you
been reading anything like what are you
do you read sci-fi primarily or
where do you land uh I mentioned I'm
going to be non-fiction but
um I am right now I'm like reading stuff
to help prepare for other things that
I'm working on so uh reading a lot of
scripts and reading
um some kind of true stories from the
Wild West
to prepare for a novel and a screenplay
that I want to work on
um best sci-fi I've read lately
um uh some older
books have been on the last few years
like this is how you lose the time War
which I loved uh the anomaly this uh
French
um uh sci-fi book
um there's so much good stuff out there
I'm reading constantly all the time but
I just read a couple of Fletch books
just for Nostalgia old Gregory McDonald
books so I'm all over the place
that's great well I want to thank you
for the the time that you gave me
um hopefully we can do this again
hopefully this is going to be a
long-term project the The Silo series
um I I can't stop thinking about it so
uh of course you know I'll take any
chance I can to talk about it and yeah
let's do it again let's let's at least
do it every season yeah absolutely
um we'll definitely talk about that is
there anything else you want to wanna
throw out there before I let you go or
uh no man just I hope everybody enjoyed
the show and uh share you know share the
news with your friends like the the more
um viewers we get the the more seasons
we get to make so keep spreading the
word
all right well thanks again
thanks Pete